MOST ADMIRED DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR BUT GROW OLD AND
IRRELEVANT?
NEXT THING YOU KNOW THEY WILL BE
ASKING YOU NASTY QUESTIONS ABOUT
YOUR IMPEACHMENT.
BEST-SELLING AUTHOR MARK STEYN
HAS NEVER BEEN IMPEACHED AND AT
THIS POINT IT SEEMS FRANKLY
UNLIKELY THAT HE WILL BE BUT HE
JOINS US ANYWAY TONIGHT.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU TUCKER.
>> Tucker: SO ALL OF A SUDDEN
BILL CLINTON FOR MANY YEARS
PROTECTED BY THE PRESS IS UP FOR
GRABS.
WHAT IS THIS?
>> I THINK THERE'S A SENSE, AS
YOU SAID THAT HE IS NOW
DISPOSABLE, BUT ALSO AT HIS
CURRENT LEVEL I DO THINK THERE
IS A GREAT SHAME AT WHAT THE
RATIONALE FOR CLINTON IS    IN T
RATIONALE FOR CLINTON IS    IN E
RATIONALE FOR CLINTON IS    IN '
RATIONALE FOR CLINTON IS    IN
'90s.
THE MOST INTERESTING MOMENT TO
ME, THE MOST HORRIFYING MOMENT
ACTUALLY AND THE MOST PATHETIC
AND SELF-SERVING MOMENT IN THIS
TODAY SHOW INTERVIEW COMES WHEN
HE PLEADS IN MITIGATION AND IT'S
INTERESTING TO LOOK AT HIS
FACIAL EXPRESSION AS HE SAYS
THIS THAT I HAD A
SEXUAL HARASSMENT POLICY AS
GOVERNOR IN THE 1980s.
IN OTHER WORDS, THAT'S THE
LESSON THE DEMOCRATS TOOK FROM
THIS, THAT AS LONG AS YOU STRUCK
THE RIGHT ATTITUDES IN PUBLIC,
YOU COULD DO -- TRY THIS IN ANY
OTHER ASPECT OF YOUR LIFE.
HEY, BUD, YOU ARE DOUBLE PARKED.
>> IT'S OKAY, OFFICER.
I VOTED FOR THE MUNICIPAL
PARKING LOT EXPANSION BILL IN
1973.
THAT'S BASICALLY THE ARGUMENT
THAT CLINTON IS MAKING HERE
BECAUSE HE PASSED THE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT BILL IN THE
1980s, BECAUSE HE SIGNED ONE
AS GOVERNOR HE IS ALLOWED TO
ACTUALLY ASSAULT WOMEN OR ENTER
INTO THE GRADING RELATIONSHIPS,
SUPPOSEDLY CONSENSUAL
RELATIONSHIPS BUT RUINED IN THE
CASE OF MONICA LEWINSKY A YOUNG
WOMAN'S LIFE.
AND THAT'S THE RATIONALE THAT
HARVEY WEINSTEIN AND
SCHNEIDERMAN, THE NEW YORK
ATTORNEY GENERAL AND ALL THESE
OTHERS AND JOHN CONYERS, THE BIG
DEMOCRAT BIGSHOT WHO WAS HOSTING
TROUSER LIST MEETINGS IN HIS
CONGRESSIONAL OFFICE.
THEY ARE ALL ACTUALLY FOLLOWING
THAT CLINTON RATIONALE BUT
BECAUSE I HAVE THE RIGHT
ATTITUDES IN PUBLIC I CAN DO
WHAT I LIKE IN PRIVATE.
>> Tucker: HARVEY WEINSTEIN'S
DEFENSE WAS I LOVE ABORTION, SO
BACK OFF, LEAVE ME ALONE.
SO QUENTIN, I CONFESS I FEEL A
LITTLE SORRY FOR BILL CLINTON
BECAUSE IN MY VIEW OF THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY CHANGING AND REJECTING ITS
PAST.
BUT I ALSO WONDER AS LONG AS WE
ARE GOING TO HAVE A RECKONING
WITH CLINTON OVER HIS BEHAVIOR,
WHEN DID WE GET THE RECKONING
WITH ALL OF HIS DEFENDERS IN THE
MEDIA?
"THE WASHINGTON POST" REPORTER
WHO SAID THAT SHE WOULD GET ON
HER KNEES FOR HIM FOR KEEPING
ABORTION LEGAL.
THE FEMINIST LEADERS WHO
ATTACKED MONICA LEWINSKY IN
EFFECT AND DISMISSED THE
ALLEGATIONS.
WHEN DO THEY GET THEIR TIME
UNDER THE SPOTLIGHT FOR WHAT
THEY DID?
>> AND I THINK THERE'S ALSO
OTHER ONES TOO.
THERE WERE ONES WHO DIDN'T
ATTACK MONICA BUT I REMEMBER FOR
EXAMPLE BEING ATTACKED IN CANADA
BY A FEMINIST COLUMNIST WHO SAYS
YOU ARE WRONG ABOUT -- MONICA
ISN'T THE VICTIM HERE.
IF SHE'S GOING TO MAKE MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS.
SHE HAS HAD A MISERABLE 20
YEARS.
SHE WAS ESSENTIALLY RUINED AND
TOSSED ASIDE BY BILL CLINTON AND
AS WE SAW IN THIS INTERVIEW HE
THINKS THAT HE IS THE VICTIM
HERE AND HE'S OUT, BY THE WAY.
HE'S ON A BOOK TOUR PEDDLING
THIS NOVEL HE SUPPOSEDLY -- WITH
JAMES PATTERSON AND SUPPOSEDLY
IS MOST AMBITIOUS WORK OF
FICTION SINCE HIS DEPOSITION IN
THE PAULA JONES CASE.
CLINTON IS GETTING A BAZILLION
DOLLARS TO PUT HIS NAME TO THIS
LUDICROUS NOVEL AND MONICA
LEWINSKY IS SOMEONE WHO HAS
NEVER HAD A FULFILLED CAREER,
NEVER HAD A FULFILLED FAMILY
LIFE AND THAT DOESN'T MATTER
BECAUSE THE CLINTONS JUST
DISCARD PEOPLE AND MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT BIT OF HUMAN DEBRIS.
>> Tucker: AND THE MEDIA GOES